sentence has just been handed down at
the old lady to a man who murdered two
sisters uh in a park in north london
last year let's go straight to sky's
crying correspondent martin brunt at the
bailey martin
yes daniel hussain who is still only 19
was 18 at the time of these murders has
been given a minimum
life sentence of 35 years
so 35 years for each of the two murders
of nicole smallman and bieber henry her
sister
he
stabbed them in a frenzied attack
last summer
during a party the two sisters were
celebrating with friends and stayed on
in the park
to continue their partying
daniel hussain
came across them
a premeditated attack
according to the prosecution and the
judge
it was pointed out by the judge in the
last few minutes that if he had
been older if he'd been 21 he could well
have been facing a full life sentence
but his age precludes that so in the
last few minutes the judge
has given
daniel hussein a minimum
35 years jail sentence for each of uh of
the two murders
it was said during his trial that daniel
hussein
suffered from autism spectrum disorder
but he never offered any explanation for
his actions
uh he refused to give evidence on his
own behalf during his trial
was found guilty in july of both of
those murders the judge said today that
no medical evidence has been put forward
to explain your actions autism
diagnosis does not
explain what you did
this case remarkable
not just for the savagery of the murder
of the two sisters but also for what
police found
when they searched daniel hussain's home
they found what appeared to be a
handwritten contract that he had
he believed he had made with a demon
in which he was offering to
kill sacrifice six women every six
months
and in return for that
he was going to win the lottery that was
the bizarre contract that police found
in his bedroom
and it goes some way to explain perhaps
his thought process
but the judge
said today in the last few minutes that
bizarre
though you're packed with the devil may
seem to others
i should also point out that um
during this morning's hearing um hussein
hasn't been in court he's been on a
video link from belmar prison
where he's been held for more than a
year
he appears to
appear to be showing great disdain for
the whole process this morning
at one point
squatting on his chair in a very bare
room in belmont prison but as the judge
started talking he turned the chair
around and appeared to be staring out of
the window
and at one point
was yawning
as as the judge was talking
the judge said that she was quite
satisfied he knew exactly what he was
doing
doing that night
and
as i said made the point that but
for his young age
18 at the time
he could have been facing a whole life
sentence in prison
in this
very sad case has left the police with a
lot of questions to answer as well
yes it has it's um it's far from over
um the bodies of the two women weren't
found for
nearly two days after they were reported
missing their mother mina smallman
uh a former archdeacon
complained to the police that
their
search for the bodies
had been perfuncturing
and had indeed been called off
very early
the independent office for police
conduct
last week
decided that it agreed with the mother's
complaint and found that the
metropolitan police's search
had been inadequate the commissioner
dame cressida dick
from scotland yard had apologized and
has offered to meet the family of of the
two sisters
um but we don't know whether that's
happened
the commissioner apologized she wanted
to make that apology face to face with
the family
it seems at this stage that the family
have
we think still not taken up that offer
to meet the commissioner
and even after that there are other
issues
still being explored around this whole
case there are two metropolitan police
officers
who have been charged with taking
unauthorized photographs of the women's
body while they
were left to guard the scene
while forensic searches were still being
carried out
those two officers are due to appear
here
later next week
so we don't know what's going to happen
in that case but again
the issue of the police
actions
several in several different directions
will be explored
after today's sentencing